la pandémie a frappé le printemps
dernier
ce quad core king venait tout juste de
lancer la construction de l'immeuble qui
abrite son espace de travail
collaboratif
l'entreprise a dû revoir l'aménagement
de ces locaux on ne peut réduire de 35%
le nombre de bureaux qu'on avait dans
nos espaces ouverts puis plutôt opté
pour des bureaux fermés puis également
changé notable pour des tables
individuelles
la coved amène des contraintes
supplémentaires mais aussi une nouvelle
clientèle
stéphanie déry a décidé de louer un
bureau ici plutôt que de travailler de
la maison surtout les fédés dans un
environnement professionnel avoir
quelqu'un qui devront toujours le matin
donc et moi travailler de la maison sur
la rue du moment pour concentrer mon
travail de dans un même lieu puis avoir
d'énergie de l'ambiance qui règne ici
c'est un cinq minutes ça se fait à pied
ça à côté de la garderie donc au niveau
de la gestion familiale sectaire c'était
parfait la plupart des membres actuels
sont ici parce qu'ils ont besoin de
rencontrer les clients dans un espace
sécuritaire
ils veulent pas les inviter à la maison
puis de toute façon il n'y arrivait pas
à se concentrer à la maison sur la table
la cuisine
une tendance qu'on observe aussi
ailleurs comme dans cet espace de
travail collaboratif d'hochelaga
maisonneuve
depuis la réouverture en juin la moitié
des clients sont des employés qui ont
perdu leur lieu de travail
toute la clientèle de télétravail
justement qui étaient dans des bureaux à
20 dans les tours de bureaux au
centre-ville qui se retrouve maintenant
la maison sont des fois parfois tu
années de travail de la maison sont soit
improductifs fillon les enfants donc
c'est sûr qu'ils ont besoin de changer
d'air
le télétravail pourrait causer une
petite révolution dans les espaces
collaboratifs
il ya des chances que ce soit les
employeurs qui de plus en plus offre
comme commodité de pays une partie des
espaces de coworking ou la totalité pour
permettre à leurs employés d'avoir un
environnement autre que la maison pour
travailler mais gabriel campo ne
participera pas à cette transformation
avec un bail qui arrive à terme et
l'incertitude qui plane il a décidé de
fermer son espace de co travail ici
olivier bachand radio canada montréal